[Music]
junkies show with how Rudnick Shh hey
screen junkies you know there's a few
things I love unconditionally peanut
butter commercials were babies talk and
the x-men just kidding commercials are
babies talk make me dive inside the new
x-men movie Days of Future past has
slowly been releasing more and more info
like the fact that they just cast Peter
Dinklage awesome but the question on
every fans mind is is this movie gonna
be any good or are we gonna have another
x-men 3 scenario talking rounder y'all
we brought an esteemed panel of experts
in to discuss this feels like way more
steam than I thought we gave them yeah
good job so guys today we're asking the
question will the next x-men suck and we
have an esteemed panel of experts
helping us figure out whether it's gonna
be good or not first we have comic book
writer he wrote the graphic novels torso
Manhunter and Captain America mark and
Rico and from the Nerdist and from g4 be
lovely and Iggy Allison hey sit with my
esteemed face and you've probably seen
this guy all over your TVs in a million
commercials Mike Carlson Mike are you so
uh in order for the audience to be able
to relate to where you're coming from
I'd like to hear your favorite of the
five existing x-men films Allison this
does not include the Saturday morning
cartoon shoot I'd love the Saturday
morning cartoons means exclude that so
let's just go down low I'm mark I would
say x-men one is probably my favorite
because Bryan Singer is responsible for
bringing respects to superhero movies we
have a future choice not them Allison I
will go with x-men one is my favorite
out of all of them Mike my favorite is
x-men too when Wolverine plunged his
claws into a man's chest I got a little
emotional
I didn't cry but I was like this is what
I always wanted to see x-men Days of
Future Passed directed by Bryan Singer
is on the horizon mark can you give us a
quick synopsis of what the plot of Days
of Future past will be not the movie but
the comic book they're using as
inspiration mutants are being killed and
interred in giant sentinels or doing
things like melting Wolverine to nothing
but his metal skeleton like I think
we're gonna get like two things from the
actual story time travel and sentinels
and that might be it big question his
Bryan Singer gonna mess this up no one
he started the franchise so he has a
deep abiding concern for it too they've
seen some of the movies go off the rails
don't you know who I am
um the geminal Bates so I think that
they've learned from blast and and
Wolverine Origins so I'm really excited
I think he's a great filmmaker the
stakes are too high over at Fox because
they don't want to look like souls in
front of Marvel across the street like
they got a lot to prove as my point I
think it's going to work because
Hollywood at this point knows that they
have to make superhero movies good
because those of us who love the product
will hate on it and not go see it if it
is bad are we okay that he's mixing the
two casts of the first three x-men and
x-men first class and creating this
bridge I would hope that they would be
mixed I would want them to be mixed my
only concern is are they going to be
mixed correctly I'm less concerned
because at the end of the day if Patrick
Stewart and Ian McKellen
are talking to McEvoy and Fassbender I'm
going to be happy there's just something
about that that will make me go yes this
is awesome I still think there's some
pitfalls I mean Bryan Singer's and
Teflon Superman Returns
that's an easy easy scapegoat for that
movie that movie took on so much crap
that it didn't deserve and yeah it's a
flawed movie but I'd rather see an
interesting Bryan Singer failure than a
Brett Ratner success people are a little
nervous about the CG cuz the CG and Jack
the giant slayer doesn't look great and
you can overlook like okay CG if the
movies good I gotta say Wolverines claws
in the Wolverine Origins story they look
terrible that didn't take out of the
movie at all the movie just the claws
the
you have better endurance than anybody
on this panel now that we're talking
about the Wolverine Origins story I know
you had an issue with gambit in that
movie when I grew up watching the
cartoons like gambit was it for me and
the fact that he felt like this kind of
like side character that they haven't
ever really quite dealt with it was
really upsetting as an x-man fan like I
could care less about Cyclops bring me
gambit blasphemy what no big news
recently Dinklage is onboard so who is
he gonna play allegedly he's gonna play
bowl of our Trask who invented the
Sentinels so I do think it's interesting
that in the comic Bowl of our Trask is
not a little person I don't think
anyone's going to care because when I
would talk to my friends when I was a
little about our favorite x-men it was
never Boulevard Trask doesn't look like
him so let's pull back and talk broader
universe there are rumors that the
Fantastic Four reboot is going to take
place in the same universe
what makes perfect sense to do that both
the x-men and the Fantastic Four kind of
science based so they're complementary
and they've been existing in the Marvel
Universe and Publishing for 50 years so
why not do we like that they're keeping
them out of the Avengers universe do we
like them separate No yeah I hate it I
want them all in one universe I want to
see them all I want spider-man to show
up at the end of Avengers but it's not
gonna happen
I want Star Wars in there too all right
give it time I want to hear your guys
ultimate nightmare scenario what would
make this film just do a Joel Schumacher
if I walk into that movie and it doesn't
make sense I will be pissed if it's like
real grounded and realistic I hate that
what can make sense and not have to be
grounded in reality because technically
if spider-man you know the real version
of that you get bitten by a radioactive
spider six months later you have bone
cancer so you don't want a - grounded
reality come on all falls apart so Bryan
Singer has said he's going to use this
next film as an opportunity to quote
correct some things what's the one thing
that you would correct are the
mismanagement of the Dark Phoenix saga
and the death of Cyclops I think that
that was just a huge waste of some of
the best most iconic comic storytelling
ever mine would be Deadpool not having
katanas shoot out of his hands that are
longer than his forearms because how
does he bend his elbows come on
so you'll suspend your disbelief and get
on board that mutants exist but you
won't suspend your disbelief when it
comes to the size of a catalysis blades
or adamantium and they don't bend point
guys make some great points you
obviously all know your stuff but
there's only one way to find out if the
movies gonna be any good we'll have to
wait and see it I want to thank my
awesome guest mark and Draco Alison
Haislip Mike Carlson thanks for being
here who would your ultimate superhero
team-up be who would you like to see
join forces and mess crap up leave us a
comment below best answer will get a
screen junkies t-shirt that's it you
guys i'm howard dick bye-bye
[Music]